in today's fast-paced and ever evolving
world of software development devops has
emerged as a transformative approach
Bridging the Gap between development and
operations team devops tools are pivotal
in streamlining the software delivery
process four string collaboration and
empowering organizations to achieve
continuous integration deployment and
delivery here we present a curated list
of top devops tools that have
revolutionized the industry the power of
these devops tools lies in their ability
to enhance productivity scalability and
reliability enabling organization to
deliver high quality software faster and
with confidence from Version Control
Systems like git and subversion to
containerization platforms like Docker
and kubernetes from configuration
management tools like ansible and
perfect to monitoring analoging tools
like promoters every tool in every step
Fosters seamless software development
and deployment ensure system health and
provides valuable insights for
troubleshooting in this DeVos tools
tutorial we will learn the top devops
tools you must focus on to become a
successful devops professional if these
are the types of videos you would like
to watch then hit the Subscribe button
like and press on the Bell icon to never
miss any further content if you are one
of the aspiring devops engineer looking
for online training graduating from the
best universities or a professional who
elicits to switch careers with devops by
learning from the experts then try
giving a shout to Simply learn skeltic
postgraduate program in devops in
collaboration with IBM the course link
is mentioned in the description box and
you should navigate to the course page
where you can find a complete audio of
the program being offered now over to
our training experts hello everyone
without further Ado let's get started
before diving into the tools let's
Briefly summarize the devops phases
devops phases are a series of
interconnected steps that streamline
software development and deployment
here's a crisp explanation of each stage
first plan Define project goals
requirements and Milestones plan takes
prioritize work and establish a roadmap
for development next is code developers
write and review code collaboratively
using Version Control Systems to manage
changes and ensure code quality the
third one is build convert the code into
executable software components including
compiling linking and packaging the code
base four-step testing automated testing
is performed to validate the software's
functionality performance and security
and this includes unit testing
integration tests and system tests the
first stage is the release stage prepare
the software for deployment by
finalizing features documentation and
versioning ensure all necessary
approvals and compliance requirements of
meth sixth one and deploy move the
software to Target environment whether
it is on-premises or the cloud this
involves setting up infrastructure
configuring resources and installing the
software now the seventh one operate
minus D is software and infrastructure
in a production environment monitor
system Health address operational issues
and ensure smooth functioning the eighth
one is monitoring phase continuously
monitor the software's performance
availability and security collect
metrics analyze logs and identify and
resolve any anomalies or bottlenecks
these stages form a continuous loop
allowing for iterative development rapid
feedback and continuous Improvement
devops enhances collaboration Automation
and efficiency throughout the software
development life cycle by integrating
development and operations team now
let's discuss the tools the primarily
used and prominent ones in each phase
starting with planning jeera and Trello
are the most popular tools jira is a
popular project management tool that
helps teams and planning face of devops
it enables teams to create and manage
tasks track progress and allocate
resources Trello Trello is a visual
collaboration tool that simplifies
project planning and organization it
provides a flexible and intuitive
interface where teams can create both
lists and cards to represent task
workflows and Milestones these tools
provide teams with the necessary
functionalities to plan organize and
track tasks ensuring Clarity
transparency and alignment of planning
phase of devops projects now proceeding
ahead we will discuss about the next
phase which is the coding phase the
important tools here are get Visual
Studio firstly get git is a widely used
distributed version control system that
plays a crucial role in coding phase of
devops it allows developers to attract
changes to their database collaborate on
a code with teammates and easily manage
different versions of their software now
the visual studio code Visual Studio
code is a lightweight versatile code
editor that provides a rich set of
features for developers it supports
various programming languages syntax
highlighting debugging and integrated
terminal making it a popular choice for
coding in the devops context these tools
get vs code provide developers with the
necessary infrastructure and
capabilities to manage code efficiently
collaborate effectively and ensure code
quality during the coding phase of
devops projects now let's proceed to the
next phase which is the build phase we
have a Jenkins Gradle and Maven in this
particular segment firstly Jenkins
Jenkins is a widely used open source
automation server that plays a crucial
role in the build phase of devops it
enables teams to automate the build test
and deployment process facilitating
continuous integrating and delivery now
the Gradle Gradle is a powerful build
automation tool that provides a flexible
and scalable framework for building and
managing software projects it supports
multiple programming languages and
offers Advanced features like dependency
management incremental bills and
parallel execution and lastly Maven
Maven is a popular build management tool
that simplifies project setup dependency
management and build processes it uses a
declarative XML based configuration and
follows conventions over configuration
principles these tools and power teams
in the phase of devops by automating the
compilation packaging and distribution
of software the Streamline the build
process ensure code quality and
facilitate efficient integration with
other stages of devops pipeline now we
will discuss the testing phase we have
three most popular testing tools
selenium junit and Postman first
selenium selenium is a widely used open
source framework for automating web
browser testing it allows teams to write
and execute automated tests across
different browsers and platforms
ensuring consistent functionality and
user experience next we have junit junit
is a popular testing framework for Java
applications it provides a simple and
standardized way to write and execute a
unit test allowing develop first to
verify and the correctness of individual
code units and lastly Postman Postman is
a powerful API testing and collaboration
platform that allows teams to design
build and automate tests for restful API
Services ensure in their functionality
performance and security are integrated
Postman provides an intuitive interface
for creating and organizing test cases
making API requests and validating
responses now these tools Aid in the
test phase of developed by automating
and simplifying the testing process they
facilitate efficient testing of web
applications unit testing of code units
and a comprehensive testing of apis
ensuring software quality and reducing
the risk of bugs and issues in
production environment proceeding ahead
we have the release phase principle AWS
code deploy are the most popular release
tools and so there is a powerful open
source automation tool that helps teams
automate the release phase of devops it
allows for easy configuration management
deployment and orchestration of soft for
releases next AWS code deploy AWS code
deploy is a fully managed deployment
service provided by Amazon web services
it simplifies the release fees by
automating application deployments to a
variety of compute environments these
tools assess teams and release phase of
devops by automating deployment process
ensuring consistent and reliable
releases and simplifying configuration
management now we are in the deployment
phase Docker kubernetes and AWS elastic
beanstack are the popular deployment
tools firstly Docker is a popular
containerization platform that
simplifies the deployment phase and
devops it allows teams to package
applications and their dependencies into
lightweight portable containers Docker
provides a consistent and isolated
environment for running applications
enabling seamless deployment across
different infrastructures next we have
kubernetes kubernetes is an open source
container orchestration platform that
automates the deployment scaling and
management of containerized applications
it provides a robust framework for
managing clusters of containers across
multiple nodes followed by that we have
the elastic bean stack AWS elastic bean
stack is a fully managed platform as
service provided by Amazon web services
it simplifies the deployment phase by
abstracting the underlying
infrastructure and providing the easy to
use platform for deploying and managing
applications these tools play a vital
role in deployment phase of devops by
automating application deployment
ensuring scalability and simplifying
infrastructure management next we will
be taking care of operate phase
Prometheus elastic stack basic Duty are
the popular operate tools firstly
Prometheus Prometheus is an open source
monitoring and alerting Tool widely use
an operate phase it collects metrics
from various systems services and
applications allowing tools to monitor
performance availability and resource
utilization next we have elastic stack
or elk stack elk stack is also known as
elasticsearch long stash and hibana
which is a powerful combination of Open
Source tools used for log management and
Analysis in the operate phase
elasticsearch stores the index's log
data logs Dash collects and processes
logs and Cabana provides a user-friendly
interface for searching analyzing and
visualizing log data now the page of
Duty pager duty is an incident
management platform that helps teams in
the operate phase of devops to respond
and resolve incidents quickly it
provides a real-time Alert in on-call
schedules and escalation policies
ensuring that the right team members are
noticed and engaged during incidents now
these tools are instrumental in the
operate phase of devops by providing
monitoring log management and incident
response capabilities and finally we
have the monitoring phase nargios and
grafana are the most popular monitoring
tools firstly we will have it discussed
about the nodules nagios is a widely
used open source monitoring tool that
plays a crucial role in monitoring ways
of devops it enables teams to monitor
the health and performance of their
systems applications and network
infrastructure next we have grafana
grafana is also one of the popular data
visualization and Analytics tool
commonly used in Wonder face of devops
it integrates with various data sources
including monitor systems and databases
to create a visually appealing and
interactive dashboard these tools are
essential and monitored phase of devops
as they provide the necessary
capabilities and monitoring
visualization and Analysis of system
performance metrics and logs they enable
themes to proactively Monitor and
optimize their applications and
infrastructure ensuring Optimal
Performance availability and user
experience and with that we have
finished the top devops Tools in 2023.
now before we conclude let us hear from
our Learners about their success story
after getting certified by simply learns
postgraduate program from Caltech in
collaboration with IBM
foreign
[Music]
we're actually brothers and we live here
in Alberta Canada we do a lot of things
together
and this time we decided to take a
course in devops from Simply learn the
course proved to be very beneficial for
both our careers yeah I got a promotion
after the course and I got a hire with a
new company
I'm actually a mechanical engineering
graduate and I've been working at my
company for the last four years in 2020
I came to know that my company was
starting the hiring process for devops
infrastructure team at the time I was
working as an implementation specialist
and my colleagues recommend that I take
a course in devops if I wanted to be
part of a team so I started doing my
research and then he came to me saying
that he was also looking for a devops
course yeah funny enough I actually
found the course through Instagram but
you know my situation was slightly
different I had been working as a
geomatic field technician for about four
years but I wanted to change my career
into something that involved more
programming and automation so when I
came across with this course I said you
know what let's take it
and caltex name was definitely a
deciding factor in July 2021 we got our
certifications and I immediately posted
that on my LinkedIn profile you know
coincidentally in November of that same
year we got the good news
and I got hired as a dis developer
which has allowed me to do way more
programming which is what I wanted to do
around that time I got promoted to the
devops infrastructure team and saw a 21
salary hike the overall course was
awesome but the part that I enjoyed the
most was a Docker certification training
you know what I also really enjoyed the
docker certification training I think
there were brothers after all
yeah the experience was amazing and
being able to study together was
definitely very nice yeah it brought us
back to those good old days when we were
going to school together and with and we
have come to an end of this session on
top devops Tools in 2020 should you have
any queries or concerns regarding any of
the topics covered in this session then
please do let us know in the comment
section below and our team of experts
will be more than happy to resolve all
your queries at the audience until next
time thank you Stacy keep learning and
get ahead
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign